welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka the guy who
misses vision like a hole in the head
in this video we're breaking down some
one division theories
the show is slowly giving a census every
week but some huge questions still
remain
namely who the big bad of the entire
season is
now though monica came out blaming
wonder for all at the end of episode 4
i personally believe that this is a red
herring and that she's actually being
manipulated
we're not even at the halfway point of
the series yet and with five episodes
remaining
it makes more sense that this is a
misdirect and that the real villain is
hiding in plain sight
the greatest trick that the devil ever
pulled was convincing the world that he
didn't exist
and throughout this video we're going to
be discussing why tyler hayward is
potentially the big bad of the show
along with a lot of other theories the
first of those is actually who the
person under witness protection really
is
i think that we've finally figured it
out although i have seen a lot of people
guessing that this could be
dotty from what jimmy says we know that
it's a man
down the road in west view and this
morning it looked like he flew the coop
so jimmy saying he flew the coop narrows
it down to being only the male
characters
initially i did think this might be norm
due to the communist comment in episode
2
however i've started to think that's
unlikely due to his face appearing on
the board
other than dottie the only person who
doesn't show up on it
is the mailman now this is likely
because all of the characters on it are
from episode 1
and sword hadn't come across him at the
point of assigning the ids
however after re-watching all four
episodes back to back
i think he does give us some hints to
his true role on the
outside from the sword necklace in the
beekeeper uniform
we know that upon entering the bubble
that there are certain things which hint
to us are what a person was actually
like outside
and these are altered to fit whatever
sitcom style it is
someone under witness protection
normally gets put there for giving
information
and a mailman's job in general is to
pass things on
mailmen also move about from place to
place and this could signify that he's
not just being stationary in west view
in addition to this when we see the
character in episode 2 agnes says to him
stick him up stick him up
don't shoot i'm just a messenger
from the trailer we know there's a big
halloween scene in which agnes tells
vision that he's dead
and it seems like she knows what's going
on in the outside world
and therefore i feel like with the stick
em up comment that she's making jabs at
him because if
anyone caught the guy he'd be a dead man
just make sure you kill him after he
delivers my ps5 yeah
now this mailman scene in the show comes
across very
out of place as it pretty much stalls
the entire moment
and doesn't seem to mean anything at all
on my first watch i was a bit unsure why
they even left it in the edit
as it's almost pointless unless it has a
deeper meaning
with the hindsight of him being a
messenger that relays information
to me it does hint to him being the
person under witness protection
due to what he says now as for the true
big bad of the show
i believe that it's in fact tyler
heywood who could actually be mephisto
or the grim reaper though wonder is now
thought to be the show's antagonist
i think that the east view police
officers existing outside of the bubble
show that someone externally is
influencing those that go there
as we know from the ending of episode 4
with monika upon leaving the bubble
one is aware of what went on inside and
they're able to tell others
thus i think this kind of shuts down the
theory that the police went inside
and then came out with their mind and
memories altered
to me them being under this control
cements that someone else has influenced
them to keep stump
and not breathe a word of what's going
on they would have to exist on the
outside
to keep them under this hypnosis though
as when someone enters the bubble
they seemingly fall under the control of
wonder in order to pull off this level
of mind control the person would have to
have incredible abilities
and therefore it could be that it is in
fact mephisto doing this
now throughout the show we have seen
from agnes that
she's mentioned her husband ralph who up
until this point
hasn't been seen at all she's almost
mentioned as much as i've mentioned
mephisto in these breakdowns
and we haven't seen him either now we've
been told that he looks better in the
dark
and that their anniversary is june 2nd
which is the day of the first salem
witch trials
however we still haven't had a look at
him and it could be possible that this
is because he actually exists outside
the bubble
and whilst we don't know if mephisto is
in the show for definite
and let's be honest i'm gonna look
stupid if he's not there have been some
other minor clues laced throughout the
four episodes
the trip to bermuda baby could be
referencing the bermuda triangle
aka the devil's triangle the setting of
new jersey could be a nod to the new
jersey devils
and i probably should have stretched
before reaching this horde however
the word big red has appeared at several
points including on a cinema placard and
as the name of the chewing gum that made
vision act like my mum when she was
pregnant with me
now that obviously explains why i'm such
an idiot and there was also a pregnancy
book which looked very
occult and hexagons have appeared at
multiple points
these are clearly tied to wonder and the
west view reality in general
and therefore we can take that they have
some significance in the show
so far we've only seen them in the
bubble except for one time in tyler's
office
when his accomplishments and
certificates were laid out to form a
hexagon
shout out to new rockstars for pointing
that out and tyler also sat in front of
a wireframe map
of the world perhaps showing what his
plans could be down the line
tyler's job description could also be a
hint towards what he actually does as
well
the show is of course based heavily on
sitcoms and it's been theorized that
some of the characters that are part of
it
are actually acting in order to trick
wonder into going through with their
plans
it's very fourth wall breaking at points
and there could be a clever clue that's
already been given to us
about what tyler really does his
position of acting director
has two double entendres in it and if we
take it literally
he could be the director of those acting
in it there's of course the word acting
which ties into what's going on
and a director in general is someone who
works behind the scenes
telling people what to do and making
sure that they keep to his or her vision
but not intended haywood was also the
only character outside of darcy that
knew about relic radiation in general
perhaps hinting at to how long he's been
around for if you also take the idea of
sword being a mirror of shield
then we already know that alexander
pierce was a bad dude
and the clues just all sort of fit
together if you want to see them
i think we know that going forward
monica will probably follow in her
mother's footsteps
and is sent to be the director of the
agency and in order to do this
hayward is gonna have to get out the way
he's pretty much grounded all their
operations
and made the company look at earth
rather than the stars
meaning that he's very much an opposite
to what it is that they do
the guy just doesn't seem to fit the
role for me and whilst
he may not be the villain something
about him seems
off i have thought about this theory for
a while
well over the weekend yeah which is like
a yeah in heavy spoilers brain time
and the main thing that i always got
hung up on was why would hayward send
out one of his best agents to spy on one
day
i couldn't get my head around it and
then all of a sudden it made
sense he wants to frame wonder so that
she brings about her own demise
and then he can come in and get what
he's really after to me it seems like
the plan the entire time was to get
wunder pregnant
and steal her kids so that he could use
them for his own nefarious means
the first part of this was done through
mr hart asking why
she envisioned didn't have children and
then the reinforcement of the for the
children event
made it so that she created them haywood
knows that she's one of the most
powerful beings in the universe
able to alter reality and thus he has to
turn the world against her so that the
avengers
doctor strange and so on eventually
helped to take her out for him
we know that benedict cumberbatch is
going to be featuring in the show
and he's likely going to pop up at the
end when she's gone too far
with her out the way and then vision
only likely being alive because
she's trapped in this reality heywood
can come in and take custody of tommy
and billy
the reason that he sent monica in was so
that she could see
firsthand that wonder was controlling
what was going on in west view
and that they had to stop her in order
to save the town
monica being one of the best agents that
sword has would be a powerful testimony
to just how
far that wonder has gone off the deep
end and thus everyone would turn their
eyes towards her
and away from what could really be going
on now if you know the source of
material then you know that in the
vision and skull at witch graphic novel
that billy and tommy were actually
carrying demon souls
if this is carried across to the series
then hayward's plan could be to take
them under his wing
and then rule over the earth with two of
the most powerful mutants on the planet
in wiccan and speed i mean who else are
they gonna go to if their mother is
killed
the fallout from west view will make it
seem like people with incredible
abilities need to be kept in check by
the government
and then hayward would pretty much gain
custody of them
that is of course just a fan theory for
now but i think when the guns start
pointing towards her
we may see that someone behind the
scenes has been manipulating the events
of the series for their own ulterior
motives
that would be the acting director
directing
those to to kill her anyway let's just
shut up if you're enjoying the video so
far then i'd massively appreciate a
thumbs up
and also make sure you subscribe to the
channel for coverage on the show
each and every week cheers now another
thing i've been thinking about
is the return of maria as we know west
view is a place where the dead can come
back to life
and i actually think that this show
purposely showed us monica's big loss
because further down the line her mother
will return in some form or another in
order to tempt her
monaco will likely be pivotal in the
destruction of west view
and a powerful driving force against
this would be potentially being reunited
with the person
she never got to say goodbye to we know
from the conversation between her and
hayward that moniker is the first person
to return to work
showing that she's likely trying to bury
her head and distract herself from
what's going on
there's also an image of two women
hugging on a news bulletin board shown
at sword
perhaps hinting to us just how bitter
monika probably feels
being the only person who seems to have
lost out i definitely think that we had
a big focus on the death of her mother
early on in her arc to show us the one
thing that could tempt her down the line
and i wouldn't be surprised if maria
doesn't return in some form or another
speaking of people returning we also
learned from hayward that there were
several snapped astronauts that were in
space
who are now stranded after being brought
back by the blip
this could easily set the fantastic four
on the mcu
and i would love to see their upcoming
films tie directly into this
as we know from the early mentions of
wakanda thanos and so on
marvel love putting things in place that
they can then build upon
i feel like this line is definitely
setting up what's to come
anyway those are our main theories after
episode 4 and i'd of course
love to hear yours in the comments
section below as a thank you for
interacting with the video you'll be
entered into our prize through on the
28th of february in which we're giving
away three copies of the marvel phase 3
box set to our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the theories
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter
at heavyspoilers if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our breakdown of the fourth episode
which will be linked on screen right now
we go over the best easter eggs in it
give some more theories
and just talk in general about where the
show is going
love it if you watched that but if not
thanks for sitting through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace